what is going on there citizens the
reject Nation we are back for One Piece
episode three today rejoined by Aaron
Alexander Aaron how are you Alexander I
am doing good that's that's good that is
Baseline we have created on camera
Rapport
ladies and Gentlemen please go ahead
leave a like on this video that would be
very much appreciated also subscribe and
click that notification Bell to get
notified when our next reaction from One
Piece is up here on the channel as
always full-length Reaction watch along
where you sing with your own copy oh
face the battle for our super sex
rejects over and on patreon page recover
several things exclusive over there
reaction Watchdogs recruited how does
Eminem do it thank you damn these
highlights let's get to it
thank you
the Pirates are coming
Pirates the players are coming oh no way
his whole life
the boy who cried wolf that's hilarious
there are no Pirates haven't been in
years that's where you're wrong I know
they're coming the Great Captain usop
will protect you this place is called
real Street r-e-e-l ah you should live
there
[Laughter]
it's ready
what is it or Jolly Roger every pirate
crew has to have one and now we do they
brought it to life Aaron from the anime
we haven't seen we've probably brought
it to life they did it I'm sure they're
all crying tears of joy right now
[Music]
we're taking in water what did you do I
didn't do anything we're gonna need a
better ship if we want to make it to the
Grand mine worthy of the straw hat crew
Like Straw Hat goofy famous Tick Tock
sensation
what a reference
so where do we get that our closest bet
is the gecko Islands we can probably
make it there before our ship sinks
those the gecko islands where that kid
is who's been exclaiming for years that
the Pirates are coming
prove yourself if you're gonna sail
under me I love the juxtaposition on the
color schemes where like when you're
with our crew the straw hat it's like
colorful here it's just like so black
and white and gray and washed out yeah
very plain I'm trying to do this clean
look thing hey what do you think you're
doing I already tied that knot that
would have slipped I'm just trying just
trying to show me up uh oh never mind I
don't think he's gonna become a hero no
it's still a little which one of
you secured this rigging he did Sir is
that true
wow so if I not son you've spent time at
Sea yes sir I have why don't you come
with me
what about me
[Music]
I would have hoped your father would
have taught you better
Marine would figure that Bounty anyway
you're kind of a wanted man yourself now
wow what is fish lens kind of deals
what's going on here
uh
rage shot
Fresh Start
you're right
what is this is crazy
it's like the drug cam what's going on
so I feel like there's something
watching them
yeah I get that feeling oh I guess
Buggy's still in this
little runt nobody makes a fool of Buddy
the clown oh
venomous I was gonna team up with
someone Boogie the Clown
[Music]
holy what is this what in the shark
man is this harlong wants a word and I
don't take requests
okay that is a superpower right there
that is beautiful is that their ship or
the classic ship I don't know but I hope
so I like it like the the goat design
it's finding love for the ship
yeah real beauty huh he taking that
thing you can talk no over here
Canon Dex 4 and aft
is you fast the fastest is he
bullshitting
the owner of the ship just happens to be
my closest friend in the world
she owns the whole Shipyard she's rich
rich I'm sure you can strike a deal with
her they're going to piss him off
they're going to piss off a lot
it is
you play a little so good I can't tell
if you've taken such a liking to him or
just wants to use him because he thinks
he can get to the Pirates maybe a little
of both let's see if you can do more
than tie knots
I've never seen a house this big before
great transition guys giving me an open
invitation to drop out anytime I want
wow
look at the panda and the tiger
oops you know there's actually a more
exclusive interest back this way
he is not invited you ain't welcome here
you know it I know nothing of this sort
I'm here to give Kyle an extra special
gift
well hello there sick what's going on
with you
in here happy birthday you remember this
of course I did no
well where do I know this guy from
I brought some of my crew is he talking
about us
you almost stay for dinner when do we
eat not dressed like that you will bathe
and change before dinner how horrible
[Music]
I don't know I feel like there's
something percolating here there's
something soon
you can't trust don't trust those eyes I
don't trust that hair of his it's too
oily
[Laughter]
I wanted to give you your birthday
present
are they lovers
yeah
a giant Pearl uh
huh
my ship almost capsizing to find it
[Laughter]
[Music]
a child a goldfish
voice down
oh she is sick
thank you
blue tea fascinating when you've been
sick as long as I have you get used to
it because tea is the only thing that
makes me feel better or is the tea
making her sick I'll keep going on these
Grand Adventures as long as you want to
hear them I wouldn't miss them for the
world oh I like them together they have
good chemistry they're cute hey does
that Butler seem familiar to you guys
yes I was saying the same thing
rich people don't have the same emotions
we do the stuff this stuff doesn't make
her feel lonely and makes her feel
important yes I identify very much so
um
I'm sure we can work out a way to get
that shipped rich people don't stay Rich
by giving things away yes I identify
I bet I can convince Kaya to give us
that ship and when you can't we go with
your plan steal one and move on you're
on there's something so ethereal about
the way this episode in particular shot
is it feels like a fever dreams like
yeah strange the the sets and I'm trying
to understand the purpose of it stepping
into like a certain kind of world feels
very Alice in Wonderland to me yeah yeah
I definitely feel that I had nothing
when your parents took me in it has been
an honor to repay their kindness and
yours by serving you these past three
years oh my god did you kill yourself he
wants the money
hey
that's all you idiot it's a chef's
reflex you want to poison yourself do
you hear that preparations
just keeping her sick
he is villainous
what is this I'm sorry sir it won't
happen again killer
everything must be
must be of all nights oh my God it's
going to be a massive poison Fest game
you're overthinking things son you won't
win Wars if you keep playing defensive
very good sir you just keep getting in
your own way oh he does like him
two minutes
he wants to make him his protege
smartness
smart to have the ticking time clock
[Music]
let's take a look at the panel yeah yeah
I love when they can make a scene like
this engaging when you don't even know
the rules right
right I don't know what's happening
one wait what you did it these are so
good I know right reminds me of that one
time I slayed a dragon cooked it over an
open flame
[Laughter]
true story bro
you look absolutely radiant no I'm so
glad you could make it what A peculiar
episode you look familiar highly
doubtful so funky bar mirror ball Island
funky bomb
there are matters concerning the
transfer of ownership of the shipyard we
need to discuss oh God but she has
prepared your special soup
ew
tonight at midnight I will become the
soldier we want to buy the ship from you
I said mentioned that your Sailors we're
Pirates
honest to a fault we have already
defeated an evil clown rated a Marine
base and taken down a captive with an ax
we're just getting started oh my God
what are you doing
being a pirate has been my dream
he just doesn't understand how other
people it's over at the end of the
journey
the one piece and they come King of the
Pirates
you have a beautiful ship out there a
caramel with a sheep figurehead it spoke
to me that's the ship we need to follow
our dreams I promise you we'll take care
of it oh my God she's gonna say yes
so inspiring we spotted the wreckage of
an abandoned Sloop
I found this on board
they lost it already dang that was so
quick I want those pirates found yes sir
not you him nepotism can only get you so
far his hair reminds me of the villain
from Puss in Boots too haven't seen it
oh you should it's really good I
have run this estate for Miss Kaya for
years so it is only natural that she
should ask me to run the family business
prick then she can tell me herself oh
dude you're signing your death wish
death warrant right now
here it is murder
oh oh he's fast he's a quicksman
under the hand through the heart
oh no Edward scissors
oh my God
[Music]
cool look though that's like two
villains in a row have like the the
blades at the end of the hands because
buggy did it too with his yeah little
fists it's cool look it is pretty dope
20 million oh he cut it up I'm here to
remind you of your place in the food
chain what are long baby you don't gotta
worry about me I'm Small Potatoes I love
their designs you know who's out there
really disrespecting you it's that
little rubber prick in a straw hat goes
by the name of Lucy oh nice Luffy's
building quite the reputation
I help you find Luffy from villain to
henchmen it's hell do you have to do
that I've got eyes and ears everywhere I
don't know I feel like he's got
something clever I think I think he can
outwit this in some way okay okay I feel
like this Show's kind of breaking him
down and then by the end of the season
he'll be like oh he's something to
really fear oh like he's gonna be like
the joke of the show and then he's gonna
come on top okay
[Music]
yeah
the one room she shouldn't have gone
into what are you doing is everything
right the house is so massive I was just
trying to find the bathroom with the
pillowcase
I'm very discreet you are a pirate after
all I hate Pirates I won't apologize for
that I find some of the decor to be a
bit gaudy I prefer to donated to charity
I'm not charity so you're not you're not
charity but take it
I give it to you because you need help
it's not as fun now
Kai are you okay everyone's so carefully
around me like one wrong move and I'll
break I don't want your pity well you
won't get it then you're a
[Laughter]
Kaya needs me is your girlfriend or
something is it for me no no we've known
each other for years ever since his
mother died it was a transition he likes
to come around and tell me all about his
Brave exploits and Grand Adventures
she's more like my best friend that's
how you love her so much your parents
what happened to them they died at Sea I
couldn't even go through their
belongings who do you think the parents
are locked up the memories in the East
wing
just her parents just her parents
some some fools that died but see I'm
actually dead maybe they just got lost
you're not very good at this friends
thing are you
she has the best laughing but we're just
friends
come on uncover the secret
great shot got it from my dad he's a
notorious pirate oh he left for a life
at Sea when I was just a baby but I
thought he feared to me back one day oh
so he would say the Pirates are coming
was he like getting excited about his
dad yeah
interesting yeah something great I know
him
he's a part of shit's crew what which
one was he the guy with the goggles if
you guys are going to talk about
feelings I'm really gonna need a drink
oh there's a wine cellar in the basement
the press it all once you tell me that
before
[Laughter]
you coming nope
this is every food
got everything I need right here oh God
don't get sick Luffy
[Music]
are you just drinking random Blue Goop
hey I'm pretty sure they keep the good
stuff over here oh it's a good thing the
butler tried to hide the body
five blades I think I've seen this
before okay so he's fought him oh not a
wanted poster your crew captain of the
black cat Pirates oh
cool reveal okay wait Cloud door is a
pirate the Dead one man he's been
playing those super long game
[Music]
oh if he's thinking that ball swords you
know he's serious you know you mean
business no what the
quick because the slingshot wait are
they like
what are they snakes snake people yeah
they got the fangs she had fangs too
yeah oh snap and their hiss was very
specific why don't you join me for
breakfast tomorrow your friends too
oh she's so sweet don't like Claude or
anyone for that matter run your life
you're stronger than you think don't
forget your pillow
oh my God I'm in love with her
she's so sweet
is she gonna put the back oh she
putting the back putting it back
[Music]
damn he's like way knocked out from that
bottle hit right oh they actually threw
him in there oh now
no Trace Left Behind
don't be dumb oh my God he's gonna do
like a sword climb thing oh that'd be
dope this is the one in his mouth
going up the mountain I'm going up the
wall
s
wait what what's happening
[Music]
he's the boy who cried wolf no one will
believe him
did it too many times but you do know
that even if he doesn't come he will I
know he will then you'll start feeling
better oh of course you were
[Music]
Mom oh is
Pirates are here I'm gonna guess yes
they really are why won't anybody
believe me oh poor guy
[Music]
oh I believe you wow I love the
complexity of this
[Music]
ah dang dab
I was really I was wonderfully complex
right there
all right well this is going to be like
a super continuation the next one will
be like a it seemed like a
word because it's like a two-parter
because each one's kind of been
contained even though it's a chapter but
this feels like one section of this
larger story
yeah what was the name of the the pirate
who took
um buggy buddy buggy buggy I don't know
shark man yeah I feel like he's probably
gonna be the main villain I can see that
yeah he's got a bit of that like
Davy Jones quality
um yeah I think I'm on the street yeah
Street Jones
yeah no I think it might be like
it'll be coming the heads of the guy
who's like the main Marine who's
manipulating the kid and that the shark
guy yeah and those would be like the the
finale villains what did you think of
the episode that was good I really
enjoyed it uh I liked getting to meet
our our new potential uh crew member
with uh with usop because we spent a lot
of time for him for not to be joining
the team yeah and yeah like the kind of
how you were commenting on the episode
uh throughout like the aesthetic of it
was really cool had a lot of really cool
shots in it and yeah I think that you
know we really got to focus on
on usab got to get a little bit more
like Nami like into you know her her
state of mind and kind of grow her
character a little bit more
um yeah I feel like even though they're
in the episode I feel like as far as
development goes Luffy and Zoro kind of
took a back seat and like let us focus
on these other characters but yeah
really a really dug it
um yeah the aesthetic was really cool
kind of how you're calling out
and yeah we're just getting to see more
of this world like the pieces are coming
together things are moving and grooving
you know and yeah we're gonna see what
what Buggy's up to because I feel like
he's not going to be uh I thought he's
gonna be a one note villain or like a
one like villain of the week kind of
thing but then I was surprised to see
him pop back up and yeah no I enjoy the
episode it's like it's part one it's
like a better Fuller feelings once we
see how this uh section of the arc wraps
up yeah I like what they're doing buggy
because it I think they're they're
stripping him down and then they're
rebuilding him back up which I think is
going to be really cool I feel like
he'll be he'll amount to something
really important
um as opposed to just like another
villain or or a threat another clown
villain and the wide Pantheon of Ip that
we have out here so I think that that's
a cool way to set him up
and and uh I'm loving what they're I'm
just so bad with names who's the Marine
Cadet guy
um Lobby
it was like Corey Kobe Kobe Kobe Kobe
yeah yeah yeah uh with Kobe I love the
build up there I actually didn't
anticipate that happening with the
everything just feels like very
multi-layered with the evil Cadet guy he
doesn't even like he comes across evil
blah blah is he really evil yet he
hasn't really done anything evil he's
just kind of doing his job right now
yeah yeah you know but you're like
there's something like really messed up
about I don't trust him I feel like he's
manipulating that kid I mean it feels
like he's manipulated him because he's
the one he knows that he can use him to
get to the Pirates yeah
um but he's getting him to buy into him
with trust as opposed to the way that
because I feel like they're doing this
kind of
uh underlying thread with him where when
you first meet him he's with that one
pirate woman who was just using and
abusing him and now he's being used
again but in a way that he'll think is
respectable and endearing when really
he's just being used yeah but it also
creates a cool complexity for him you
may say that word a lot he creates a
cool complexity for him because he
he has that relationship with Luffy he
knows that hey like yeah I know bad
Powers but Luffy's not one part of this
category that you're hunting yeah
somebody is the first person who's ever
kind to him but he's also building up
the Loyalty with the Marines
which is going to make his decision make
it even harder so I like that and it
also gives like someone who's like that
timid to uh grow I think is really neat
and then of course uh yeah I mean
everything here at the house I think was
really interesting it was really odd
strange weird eccentricities throughout
I love the twist that we got with the
the reveal of who the butler is as
opposed to just another Butler guy who
wants to inherit the fortune like it was
a little predictable of what the twist
would be on what he's really trying to
do but then the reveal it oh like he's
actually some like you know another one
of them Supernatural Pirate characters
like oh okay I didn't actually see that
coming that was clever I was really
cleverly done and I I love the
performance so again terrible names
what's what's the guy's name the guy who
just met hung out with the whole time us
up Usopp loved it I thought he was great
uh for there's so much uh an adventure
spirit that you can feel compliments
Luffy in a way where he could see them
becoming like really great friends oh
yeah and I like the people who keep
joining the band the band of Misfits
because you could you get that that
tangible feeling that Luffy is
constantly inspiring and in a way where
he might not even intend to sometimes
like he knows how to motivate he knows
how to connect and then there are times
where you know even in the most hardened
shell of people will end up
coming along the ride with him yeah it's
his his naive optimism and like his lack
of social awareness that makes him so
endearing love it yeah yeah he really
feels like a live-action anime character
that's brought to life and I was like
wow I feel like it's the first time I've
seen that that archetype truly brought
and it's like it works yes
yeah there's some good setups I mean
we're gonna watch the next episode right
away uh you know even though we're
keeping this discussion short like a
really long discussion will definitely
be reserved for the finale mm-hmm
definitely but quick thoughts on that I
think yeah good music and I think what
they're well say too is like they're
doing a really great job
completely shifting where your focus is
going every episode and they have a
challenge on their hands and they
introduce a set of new characters every
episode and to get you to buy into it
and be interested in it and they're
doing a really good job on that because
like last week or in the last week last
episode was buggy buddy buggy buggy God
damn it
buggy and then this episode you're
reading this like Alice in Wonderland
type of of flair to it and with a whole
new set of characters and then like
spoiled sick rich girl she was even
interesting I really loved her
performance she's really there's
something very melancholic and sweet
about her I really enjoyed her a lot
and and you watch how she affects Nami
and you get these teases of where growth
can be I think they're doing a a really
excellent job and and on top of that too
one thing we haven't really talked about
is like just the World building is great
oh fantastic there's like a phenomenal
World building here uh it's and I think
a lot of times when you're introducing
when you're trying to do an adaptation
of stuff that's kind of where they just
get way too bogged down and they they're
they're letting the world building sort
of naturally happen by reactions and
getting to see people and societies of
how they respond to things no it feels
all feels organic they're telling you
the information you need to know rather
than overloading you with just lore for
Laura's sake a thousand percent and yeah
I think that the way that it's playing
out it it's playing out in a way that's
organic but also makes you intrigued to
want to know more that's who want to
know all these extra details like we got
to know that usop's Dad was with Luffy
and then that uh what the what's the
girl's name I don't remember her name
[Laughter]
yeah right because the swords and stuff
he said he's your favorite character he
is my favorite character so far he's got
such a great presence it's cool and and
I I think the on-camera chemistry
between him and Luffy are phenomenal
like with just when you put them in the
same frame you're like there's such a
good pairing between them I imagine
that's what it's like one of the anime
maybe I don't I don't know what the
Dynamics are but with them two on screen
together there's such opposite
personalities yet they fit yeah and
that's that's when you got like magic in
a bottle with your cast where you're
like oh yeah they're so different they
look different they behave different
one's full of optimism and wonder the
other one is completely jaded and you
know and I love love it yeah
uh
I'm really enjoying the show it's a
really good show man yeah alrighty guys
what do you think about episode three
keep a lookout for episode four reaction
they just take some time to put together
you know so uh keep a look at we're
trying to do like an every other day
upload thank you so much for being here
again thank you all join our patreon
we'll catch you all soon
see you in just a little bit
[Music]